what's up guys some of the biggest news
in the bitcoin crypto industry just
dropped this morning blackrock which
last week announced that they were doing
a partnership with coinbase they now are
going all in on bitcoin blackrock has
trillions of trillions of dollars so the
world's largest asset manager and they
announced this morning that they are
going to launch a private trust for
their institutional clients in that
announcement they said they're seeing
tons of demand from those institutional
clients even though the bitcoin price
has fallen about 70 or so bitcoin
obviously liking this and started to rip
upwards in terms of price but here's the
thing that no one's talking about but i
think it's actually the big deal
blackrock launching a private trust to
me says that they're going to get into
the etf race now as we know in the
united states no bitcoin spot etf has
been approved by the sec yet we have all
sorts of bitcoin futures etfs and we
have bitcoin spot etfs all around the
world but we do not have a bitcoin spot
etf in the united states and so
blackrock this is what i think their
plan is going to be they're going to
launch that private trust they'll
eventually take it public it'll look
just like grayscale's gbtc product and
then they're going to go to the sec and
they're going to say we're blackrock let
us convert our private trust into the
first bitcoin spot etf now what this
does is it pits the world's largest
asset manager in the traditional world
with the largest asset manager in the
bitcoin and crypto world in great scale
and that script is literally written for
television i can't wait to see
blackrock's impact on the bitcoin market
but one thing that we should caution is
we better be careful what we wish for
blackrock is still a very large wall
street financial institution they do all
kinds of crazy stuff and the more and
more that bitcoin gets financialized the
further it gets away from that
cypherpunk dream but ultimately
blackrock getting into the bitcoin
market and providing direct exposure to
their institutional clients that means
that billions and maybe trillions of
dollars is about to enter into a fix
supply asset that only means one thing
bitcoin will keep doing exactly what
it's always done hey you did you like
this video great make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time